holy [ __ ] it's so perfect and no one's
ever done a super mario galaxy video I
caught a tiny lizard I just grabbed him
he's in my hand right now and put him in
a really big cage and he's gonna have
everything he wants
except for freedom I just came in I was
like holy [ __ ] a lizard in the office
dude look at him he might be dead no
there's no way he's dead he is I let me
just give a click just give me a little
bit more of the shot let me get a little
bit more of a chef's 300 got it oh that
is a lizard sickness dude
yeah my brother's wishes coming from
Mary Hill crows mom I think yeah I think
we took we took their king and now
they're after us
dude that's crazy well you have a live
one
he's probably too freaked out to go
after it but in that one well justice
fly oh oh
using his gear 360 Rena put together
this test clip of basically taking the
360 video and warping it into a tiny
planetoid shape which is really neat
looking and we're talking about it
trying to come with some ideas as to
what we could do what kind of story
could use little planets how I could
incorporate this into the video idea wow
this is cool he's flipped upside down
and run around like what why are you
doing that because it looks great and
some incredibly entertaining to watch
there's other ideas that we've discussed
friends on his way to the store to make
cookies cookie planet he's going to
cooking pizza world an idea where a guy
has a chair with a bunch of balloons on
it and then one of the balloons flies
away space traveler Doctor Who is type
character goes to a planet where there's
something on fire and everybody's
freaking out and running around trying
to put this fire out but they don't have
any water and moves on to the next
planet a bunch of water people are
freaking out and running around because
the water level the water is leaking out
of something they don't even the plug it
each planets a different environment
that has a singular problem that the
other planet could fix and for every
just work together
they'd be able to fix everybody's
problems I think that spills the bounds
of what we would really have time for
though with effects on this I mean for
1600 galaxies it's such a cash-in but
seriously you guys want my 10 million
views just makes your mario galaxy I'm
not even kidding
that time of the year get where we
changed up all our logos all the colors
and all the graphics that we've made we
realized we needed a more consistent
identity having a cool identity that
hops is super important in a world where
everybody's screaming at you to look at
them we are trying to be consistent we
are trying to plan for the future so
that we can stay with these colors for
years to come what not a favorite color
like a glittery purple car finish purple
car finish the car finished sparkly
purple my favorite color is chrome once
we define our branding on corridor
that's when we didn't step over 70 go
check out one I transferred over I think
this would make a great color city free
here
you will get those four colors in the
primary palette up top which one stands
out to you well exactly so that's corner
one so now we need another standout ish
color but the idea is that these colors
complement each other and these colors
this is the important part
these colors are consistent in print
Super Mario Galaxy wow that's a crazy
one you know it's funny
Super Mario Galaxy was literally the
first idea I had for this I remember
thinking I don't think it'll work
because we only have the 2d planets as
opposed to actually going up and around
and so what should I mean yeah exactly
so I I'm I'm looking at a picture of the
game it's exactly the same video look at
this how is this not what we're doing is
there holy [ __ ] it's so perfect you know
and no one's ever done a Super Mario
Galaxy video it's one of the best Mario
it basically redefined Mario it's the
only game Mario game I beat since Mario
64 but maybe that's just kind a piece of
crap in there the plays Mario should
play a little more Mario most of the
apps are normal and then everyone smile
they throw in these little 360 inspired
maps a lot of people will make a video
like this and the whole gimmick is that
it is Mario whereas I just I don't want
to use that as a gimmick I want to use
it as just like a location and
environment or our own story to like
take place literally you can do anything
you want it just has to be entertaining
Super Mario 64 Galaxie brothers the
movie the end there's so much
Julis information black hat with the
yellow inverted version there oh I mean
this looks cool on a hat but you know
you have that little box you designed
with this like offset and it's you can
still read it the offset like like
misprinted like over here okay or we'll
do the bumblebee happy on one black or
you just have a black hat with just a
clean yellow cord or logo yeah would you
guys like to see some corridor hats in
the store we have to do miss limited
editions because hats can't print them
on demand I'm gonna take that as a yes
I'm not even awake you guys answer I
know I don't work we go on hats why sell
the comments and I want to add I want a
day in corridor hat for all you guys
saying will you please do another run
like I myself do not have a hat for my
noggin yes but these are gonna be the
new ones these wait these hats
he's has forgotten wherever they were
loaded edition special edition those of
you who got the cool hats
you're cool peeps bread ate it hard that
was the way the drum oh hey here's a
freaking hole here like look at it yes
the best music oh Michael what what do
you guys do nail maybe this thumb you
see it ready
whoa what are you doing what is this